hey this is presh tollwacker
recently there was a mathematical story
that made headlines around the world
according to the guardian U.S teens say
they have new proof for two
thousand-year-old mathematical theorem
so what exactly was this impossible
proof by nicaea Jackson and Kelsey
Johnson
first a bit of review
let's say you have a right triangle with
legs of A and B and hypotenuse C the
famous formula is a squared plus b
squared is equal to c squared
this is taught by one name but to credit
the people who knew it and proved it
first it's also known as the baudian
theorem the gogu theorem the Babylonian
formula and Euclid 1.47.
now in a right triangle let's say you
have angles Alpha and beta sine of alpha
is equal to a over C and sine of beta is
equal to B over C this is right triangle
trigonometry
so there's a book which has a collection
of over 370 proofs of this formula and
it flatly states there are no
trigonometric proofs because all the
fundamental formula of trigonometry are
themselves based upon the truth of the
Pythagorean theorem because of this
theorem we say sine squared a plus
cosine squared a is equal to 1 Etc
trigonometry is because the Pythagorean
theorem is
when the students read this they didn't
accept this paragraph As the truth they
question it and in fact this is
completely false they came up with the
trigonometric proof that is independent
of the Pythagorean theorem so in fact
trigonometry is not completely dependent
on the Pythagorean theorem that is The
Impossible proof
so to get a better understanding of this
I'm first going to give an outline of
their proof and then I'm going to go
into some of the details
now in terms of the outline I want to
thank math train for its video
so the paper is not publicly available
but math train reconstructed the proof
using publicly released images and we
have a pretty good sense of what they
did in their proof
so now let's get into some of the
outline so one case is for an isosceles
right triangle this will be a short
proof
the other case is for a non-isos right
triangle
so the proof goes something like this
you have a right triangle now make its
mirror image from here you can show that
sine of 2 Alpha is equal to 2ab divided
by c squared
now comes the amazing part
construct the following line segments
which intersect and then create a waffle
shape like this so you have infinitely
many triangles
from here you can calculate the length
of the hypotenuse and the length of this
leg and show that sine of 2 Alpha is
equal to 2ab divided by a squared plus b
squared so you have two different
expressions for sine of two alpha
setting them equal to each other and
then looking at the denominators we must
have c squared is equal to a squared
plus b squared in other words a squared
plus b squared is equal to c squared and
this will be proven using only
trigonometry
so now let's get into the details of the
proof
the trigonometric proof depends upon
brahmagupta's Law of Sines which is
independent of the Pythagorean theorem
so to see why I'll give a little bit of
justification let's say you have a
triangle with sides a b and c it does
not have to be a right triangle
let's say it has angles alpha beta and
gamma the area of the triangle is equal
to one-half times the base times the
height upon the base
so let's construct the following height
upon the base C
looking at this right triangle we can
see the height is equal to B times sine
Alpha
so we can express the area as one-half
times c times B times sine Alpha
but we can also calculate this height
using this triangle and this height will
be equal to a times sine beta
so in this way we see the area of the
triangle is equal to one half times c
times a sine beta
but now we can also construct a height
here upon a in this case we're going to
see in this triangle that the height
will be equal to B times the sine of 180
degrees minus gamma
but sine of 180 degrees minus gamma is
exactly equal to sine of gamma so this
is equal to B times sine gamma so the
area is equal to one-half times a times
B sine gamma
so all of these are equal to each other
now if we divide the area by ABC and
multiply it by two we get this is equal
to sine Alpha divided by a which is
equal to sine beta divided by B which is
equal to sine gamma divided by C
so this is known as The Law of Sines and
this will be crucial for the proof so we
will need this formula right here
now also just a quick review of the sum
of geometric series let's say you have a
geometric series starting with a and a
common ratio of r
so we want to sum up n terms in order to
do that we multiply by the ratio R this
shifts all the terms over by one if we
subtract the second line from the first
line we get all these cancellations so
we have SN minus r times SN is equal to
a minus a times R to the power of n we
Factor this and then solve for SN
now if the common ratio has an absolute
value that's less than one
then R to the power of n will go to zero
as n goes to Infinity
so the limit as n goes to Infinity of
this sum will be equal to a divided by 1
minus r so it's the first term divided
by 1 minus the common ratio
so now let's get to the first case which
is of an isosceles right triangle so we
have a right triangle with sides a a and
two angles equal to Alpha
the hypotenuse is equal to C and since
the two angles are equal to each other
they're each equal to 45 degrees
so sine of alpha is equal to a over C
we will now take the mirror image of
this right triangle
so 2 Alpha will be equal to 90 degrees
so we have a right angle over here
now in this entire right triangle
sine of alpha will be equal to C divided
by 2A
so we have two different expressions for
sine Alpha so they must be equal to each
other
so a over C is equal to C divided by 2A
we can cross multiply to get c squared
is equal to 2A squared and that's really
what we want to show because 2A squared
is equal to a squared plus a squared so
c squared is equal to a squared plus a
squared and thus we have proven that c
squared is equal to the sum of the
squares of the legs so case one is done
now let's go to case 2 which is of a
non-isos right triangle so we have a
right triangle with sides a b c
and we have angles Alpha and beta with
Alpha less than beta in this right
triangle sine beta is equal to B over C
and sine Alpha is equal to a over C
now let's make the mirror image of this
right triangle and we're going to take
this right triangle and scale it and
rotate it so we've created a new right
triangle and its angles are equal to
Alpha and beta
now let's take a look at this entire
angle here it's equal to Alpha plus beta
but Alpha plus beta is equal to 90
degrees so this is another right angle
now let's calculate the hypotenuse of
this right triangle let's call it X
we know that sine beta is equal to 2A
divided by X so we can solve that X is
equal to 2A divided by sine beta but we
know that sine beta is equal to B over C
so we can substitute in and then solve
that X will be equal to 2ac divided by B
so we'll substitute that in
now what is going to be the other leg of
this right triangle
we'll calculate it in a similar fashion
let's call this y
so sine Alpha is equal to Y divided by
the length of the hypotenuse which is
2ac divided by B
we can solve this equation for y and now
we know that sine Alpha is equal to a
over C so we substitute in and we
simplify so that we get Y is equal to 2A
squared divided by B
from here we're going to construct the
next right triangle
so we will take this right triangle
and we will make the following right
triangle
so this is a right triangle and it has
angles Alpha and beta
so we're going to figure out the length
of its hypotenuse so let's say the
hypotenuse of this right triangle has
length equal to Z
we have that sine beta is equal to 2A
squared divided by B all over Z
we can solve this equation for Z and
then we know that sine beta is equal to
B over C
so we substitute in and then we simplify
to get that Z is equal to 2A squared
multiplied by C all over B squared
now from here we're going to continue
the construction
so let's just zoom this out
so these right triangles we've
constructed are similar to each other so
let's figure out their similarity Factor
in this triangle the hypotenuse has
length 2ac divided by B and in the next
triangle that we construct its length is
equal to 2A squared multiplied by C
divided by B squared so what's the
similarity Factor we need to multiply by
A over B
we can now construct the next triangle
in this sequence and it will also be
similar
so in order to get the length of this
hypotenuse we multiply by a factor of A
over B and this will be equal to 2A
cubed multiplied by C divided by B Cubed
but why stop there we can then construct
the next right triangle and we calculate
the length of its hypotenuse by the same
similarity Factor A over B so we get 2 a
to the power 4 multiplied by C divided
by B to the power 4. we do this once
again we multiply by A over B and we get
the length of the next hypotenuse and we
can keep constructing triangles like
this in this waffle cone infinitely many
times and we can continue to calculate
the lengths of each hypotenuse
so where do we go from here
so now we're going to take a look at the
lengths of the hypotenuse and the leg of
this right triangle
so what is the length of this entire leg
we can sum up the lengths of all of
these hypotenuses so we just sum these
all up
we now have a geometric series the first
term is 2ac divided by B and the common
ratio is a squared over B squared so
this sum is equal to the first term
divided by 1 minus the common ratio
we can multiply the numerator and
denominator by B squared so this
simplifies to be 2 A B C divided by B
squared minus a squared
so that's the length of this leg
so now let's calculate the length of the
hypotenuse
it'll be C plus this first term plus the
next term and so on
so this term will be a geometric Series
so we have 2A squared multiplied by C
divided by B squared that's the first
term and then each subsequent term will
be multiplied by a squared over B
squared so this is equal to C plus the
sum of the geometric Series so that'll
be the first term divided by 1 minus the
common ratio we just need to simplify
this it'll be a little bit of work but
we end up with the following this is all
equal to C multiplied by a squared plus
b squared all over B squared minus a
squared so that's the length of the
hypotenuse
so from here we can calculate sine of 2
Alpha in this big right triangle
sine of 2 Alpha will be equal to the
length of this opposite leg divided by
the length of the hypotenuse
this simplifies tremendously and it's
equal to 2 a b divided by a squared plus
b squared
now let's take this and go back to the
original two triangles
consider this triangle here
by The Law of Sines we have sine of 2
Alpha divided by 2A is equal to sine of
beta divided by C
but from the original right triangle we
know that sine of beta is equal to B
over C so we can substitute in
so we can simplify this is equal to B
divided by c squared
multiplying both sides of this equation
by 2A we get sine of 2 Alpha is equal to
two a b divided by c squared
we now have two different formulas for
sine of two alpha so we can set them
equal to each other
so we have 2ab divided by a squared plus
b squared and 2ab divided by c squared
so that implies that 2ab divided by a
squared plus b squared is equal to 2ab
divided by c squared we can cancel out
the two a b terms and then take the
reciprocal so we get the denominators
are equal to each other and thus we have
a squared plus b squared is equal to c
squared and that is exactly what we
wanted to prove so we have shown the
impossible that we have a squared plus v
squared is equal to c squared from only
trigonometry
I congratulate Nakia Jackson and Kelsey
Johnson for this genius proof it is
truly remarkable that two teenage
students questioned something they read
in a math textbook and came up with this
wonderful derivation
I also give a huge thanks to the media
for bringing great attention to this
matter
now was this the first trigonometric
proof
I will conclude the video that there are
probably some overlooked trigonometric
proofs that are ancient in origin
so how could that be that proofs are
overlooked
well I'll start out by taking a look at
the Wikipedia entry for Pythagoras in
school we are taught it's a definitive
fact that he existed and proved a
squared plus b squared equals c squared
but if you read this entry closely
you'll see that many scholars question
pretty much all the details of this
story
the theorem was known before Pythagoras
it was proven before him he may have
actually learned it from other cultures
so there's a lot of myth and
Circumstance in the history of
mathematics so we're not going to get
into that right now we'll just go over
some proofs that are probably ancient in
origin
so we'll start out with the right
triangle
so in this right triangle sine Alpha is
equal to a over C and sine beta is equal
to B over C
construct an altitude to the hypotenuse
now we have two more right triangles
so in this right triangle we have one
angle it's beta we have a right angle so
the other angle has to be equal to Alpha
so we take a look at this leg it will be
equal to a times sine Alpha
now in this right triangle one angle is
a right angle the other angle is Alpha
so the other angle must be equal to Beta
and then this leg has length equal to B
times sine beta
so we have the hypotenuse C is equal to
a sine Alpha plus b sine beta
but we can now substitute in that sine
Alpha is equal to a over C and sine beta
is equal to B over C
this gives the following equation
we can multiply both sides of the
equation by C and we get that c squared
is equal to a squared plus b squared and
right away we have a squared plus b
squared is equal to c squared from
trigonometry alone so here's another
proof that I really like we have a right
triangle with a hypotenuse equal to one
and one angle equal to Theta
the vertical distance will be equal to
sine Theta and the horizontal distance
will be equal to cosine Theta construct
a circle centered at this leftmost
vertex
by historical perspective this is how
trigonometry was actually developed
where sine Theta was the length of a
half chord and cosine Theta was the
complementary sign
so we'll construct the diameter of this
circle
now the radius of the circle is equal to
one so this distance is equal to one and
on the right hand side the remaining
distance will be equal to 1 minus cosine
Theta
now construct this right triangle so
this vertical lag will also be equal to
sine Theta
now this right triangle will be similar
to this right triangle
they're both the right triangles and
each of them has the inscribed angle
that subtends the same Arc of the circle
therefore these triangles are similar
so now since these triangles are similar
we have sine Theta divided by one minus
cosine Theta is equal to one plus cosine
Theta divided by sine Theta cross
multiplying we get sine squared theta is
equal to one minus cosine Theta
multiplied by 1 plus cosine Theta this
means sine squared theta is equal to one
minus cosine squared theta which means
sine squared theta plus cosine squared
theta is equal to one and that's exactly
what we want it to prove
what a wonderful story
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
[Music]